we'll get into the action
this is a free-to-play high-octane
shooter
combining realistic gun play with
personalized classes
[Music]
tom clancy's ex-defiant
hello and welcome back to grenade out of
nowhere ubisoft announced a new game
a multiplayer first-person shooter
incorporating the gritty nature of the
tom clancy back catalog
with the arena shooter shenanigans of
something like valorent
or overwatch and it's totally free to
play
no paywall at all if that's your thing
sit your butt down for five minutes
tickle the like button for me and let's
go through 10 things you need to know
about tom clancy's
ex-defiant
the mantra for x defiant is summed up
like this
it's fast-paced firefights meets punk
rock marsh pit
fast-paced fire fights meet punk rock
fire pits
but what the heck does that actually
mean the fire fight part is strongly
footed in the tom clancy universe with
rainbow six the foundation of most
gunfights
brutally accurate and fast if you've
been shot in the face going around a
corner
in siege you know exactly what i mean
that's the bread and butter of this game
gun play
is the thing which matters the most but
there's also a second element
each character has abilities we've seen
incindury turrets
we've seen healing pods we've seen
invisibility
and hollow shields including this one
which tracks with the whole squad
this has a great deal of potential x
defiant is a class shooter
but this time those classes are linked
to factions
there will be four of them at launch and
we can pick and choose between them on
the fly
the four factions are the wolves the
cleaners the outcasts and the echelon
each has a very different approach to
battle and when combined
they can give us some really interesting
options in fights
each of the factions are taken from
other tom clancy games
can you spot any of these the wolves
these guys are taken from ghost recon
and they will be the tank builds of
x defiant these guys have more health
and shields right away
although they do appear to be moving
slower but i haven't had that confirmed
just yet
the next two factions are from the
division the cleaners
are pyromaniacs with high dps these guys
are the ones who will deal the most
damage to the opposition in the shortest
amount of time
then we have the outcasts their
abilities are focused around healing and
reviving quickly
and finally from splinter cell we have
the echelon
sam fisher's friends who are the support
class of the game with espionage and
information-based skills
like those cool night vision goggles in
this case they can see through walls
briefly combining members of each of
these factions will give us a greater
control on the fight we take
and should we die we can change our
character our traits and the gadgets we
take with us
continuously evolving the fights in the
battlefield dynamically changing
everything
highly personalized loadouts are
promised and that's another thing that
sounds pretty good to me
and remember that's only the first four
factions to be confirmed
others will be added over time from
other tom clancy games
[Music]
let's look at the info around maps and
modes x defiant is 6 vs 6 at its core
on release 10 maps are confirmed seven
of these
are arenas and three are called linear
maps
linear maps are those used for game
modes like payload in overwatch this
time around it's called escort
the other is zone control the kind of
game mode where one team
defends as the other slowly takes ground
and progresses
on the other hand the arena maps will be
used for domination you've played it 101
times before catch and keep control
points ringleader is about collecting
rings from fallen players kind of like
kill confirm in cod
and upload is something i haven't been
able to find out so
any ideas what upload could be let me
know if you get it right i'll pin your
comment
the maps themselves will be influenced
by all the tom clancy games in the world
would you like to guess how many tom
clancy games have been released over the
years
take a second and give me a random guess
you ready
there's 41 separate tom clancy games
excluding dlc 41 how many do you think
you've played
maybe maybe 10 let's see if you
recognize any of these maps
there is a wild west backlot complete
with a saloon
there are the snowy streets which i'm
going to guess are the division there's
like a rundown village
an underground railway a storefront
there looks to be a great deal of
variety even at this very early stage of
the project
at this point we haven't been told about
the weapons we should expect
and i do not have the ability to look at
a gun and tell you its name and its
history
i think you'll find this is the m4
carbine which largely replaced the m16
in the us army in
around 2004. i have no idea what i just
said then
what we have been told for certain is
that our arsenal consists
of a primary weapon and a secondary
weapon we then have devices to take with
us
and attachments for those weapons these
can then be saved to create personalized
loadouts
ready for quick selection let's
backtrack for a moment to that word
free as it can be quite scary many of us
have been burnt by free-to-play games
which end up being paid to win
right out the gate ubisoft have
recognized this and pledged that fair
play and transparency are their core
ideology they want to build a community
around
ex-defiant and recognize fair play is
not giving those who pay
a head start i'm sure we can expect a
battle pass option or other cosmetics to
add monetary value
but a player joining a year later than
others should have the same
opportunities to succeed
as a veteran they may not have the skill
set or knowledge base
but they won't be at a disadvantage from
a pay-to-play perspective
the director of the project says they
are devoted to at least 10
years of support around this game and
want to build something
kind of special in the community sort of
like rainbow six siege but hopefully a
little more newcomer friendly
so when the heck can we play it not long
the first playtest is running on august
5th so a little over two weeks after i
make this video
you'll need to sign up if you want to
take part or if you like me you prefer
to wait to let other people play test
the game and find the books
if you want to get in early visit
playexdefiant.com
and no i'm not sponsored i'm just being
a good guy so how can we sum up this
game quickly
well let's use the official press
release which states tom clancy's x
defiant is a free to play
fast-paced first-person shooter it
combines intense gunplay
and personalized loadouts and
specialized factions as teams of
gunfighters called defiance
battle for domination okay that's quite
well put
so what are your feelings what do you
think about x defiant on this very first
day
i'm looking forward to this i've been
needing a new game for a very long time
and this looks like the type of game
which will take me away from battle
royale
what do you reckon i'll be in the
comments looking for your thoughts i'm
adam you're awesome
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you